Caption: good price one of the amazing keynotes
Caption: and breakout sessions and website
Caption: theater really and I will be your thing
Caption: that they say yes would be here boys
Caption: philosophy apologies for that it is
Caption: actually my massive pleasure for the
Caption: second year in a row we work that well
Caption: to introduce many viable to the state so
Caption: that's really introduce our functional
Caption: it's the about all and this is he's
Caption: promised us of the incredibly special
Caption: with browser censoring the eyes and a
Caption: pretty basic demo as well so without
Caption: further ado them to say hi everyone
Caption: welcome to dd8
Caption: special thanks to all of the sponsors
Caption: today
Caption: you may even be possible they like so
Caption: many of them it's really great Pacific
Caption: companies particularly but local
Caption: companies are supporting the conference
Caption: the clicker isn't working
Caption: okay my name is Mandy Michael I'm a
Caption: front-end developer and the development
Caption: manager at seven West media here in
Caption: Perth I like to experiment and to tinker
Caption: with things on the web so that's kind of
Caption: what we're gonna have a look at today my
Caption: passion is experimenting with different
Caption: front-end technologies new hat all to
Caption: see how we can combine them and create
Caption: some cool and exciting things so that's
Caption: what we're going to do today we're gonna
Caption: look at some fun that stuff we can make
Caption: the senses and brass and ice
Caption: specifically we're going to look at
Caption: three things we have a look at speech
Caption: recognition device orientation and the
Caption: ambient light sensor but before I get
Caption: into showing you some stuff I want to
Caption: take a couple of things really clear I
Caption: have to be standing upright
Caption: yes miss take it away thing number one
Caption: what we're going to be looking at today
Caption: funding experiments I'm not going to
Caption: show you anything particularly serious
Caption: with it the reason for that isn't
Caption: because you can't it's just if I wanted
Caption: to make some fun demo it's because I
Caption: like to do I talk about some fun things
Caption: that you can do but this time I'm going
Caption: to show you is just going to be some
Caption: funny examples the other thing is that I
Caption: wanted to mention is that some of the
Caption: examples that I'm going to show you are
Caption: going to have great browser support and
Caption: some not so much
Caption: I'm not really going to go into a lot of
Caption: detail about browser support I will show
Caption: you on the next by the legend of what
Caption: the support is but whatever fight can
Caption: that you do is try not to point this on
Caption: that kind of stuff take a step back and
Caption: just enjoy and listen and maybe be
Caption: inspired
Caption: kind of things that you could use this
Caption: boy in your projects now or in the
Caption: future
Caption: pretty much everything on the web
Caption: started back started out of the
Caption: experimental technology so we need to
Caption: start figuring out how to make use of
Caption: this now so this is the support legend
Caption: and the beginning of each section I'm
Caption: going to put up on the slides some
Caption: comprise my guys a full-auto means full
Caption: support if there's a flag that means you
Caption: have to enable a flag and even its star
Caption: it means it will be fully supported in
Caption: the next version so from this point on
Caption: I'm not gonna mention browser support I
Caption: can go check it out when can I use all
Caption: their MDM Docs but keep an eye out for
Caption: the logos as we go through so we're
Caption: gonna dive right in and the first thing
Caption: we know about is web speech API is ID so
Caption: the web speech API basically enables you
Caption: to incorporate different boy started
Caption: into web apps and it's split into two
Caption: interfaces there's a speech recognition
Caption: API for recognizing audio and turning it
Caption: into text and then there's a speech
Caption: synthesis API and that turns text into a
Caption: computer-generated voice what we're
Caption: going to look at today is specifically
Caption: speech recognition that is assimil art
Caption: and you can share a few things between
Caption: the two but if you want to go and check
Caption: out more about speech synthesis I highly
Caption: recommend you check out and sell his
Caption: dogs so at this point we're going to try
Caption: using the internet which is old so I
Caption: want to show you what speech recognition
Caption: looks like hello day today my name is
Caption: Mindy after my clean writing to work so
Caption: so what we're doing is speaking into the
Caption: microphone and then the speech
Caption: recognition API is trying to determine
Caption: what if what I said and you might have
Caption: noticed some of the words were changing
Caption: as it right out
Caption: that's because it thought I said
Caption: something then you've got more context
Caption: and it changed to get a more accurate
Caption: confidence rating in what I've said so
Caption: I'm going to show you how to make this
Caption: because it's pretty straightforward
Caption: it's not about me in it this is what I'm
Caption: going to show you Sukhoi there's not a
Caption: lot of co2 required to make this work
Caption: absolutely so don't worry about it if
Caption: you're not a developer I picked up the
Caption: wrong with ago so this is the first
Caption: thing that we're going to be we're going
Caption: to need to make use of the speech
Caption: recognition constructor and what this is
Caption: going to do is create an object instance
Caption: that gives us access to all the api's
Caption: methods and properties there are a few
Caption: of them for speech recognition so I'm
Caption: going to keep it really simple and just
Caption: show you the ones you need to make that
Caption: a specific example the next things we
Caption: need a couple amendments start and stop
Caption: they pretty much do what you detect they
Caption: stop the speech recognition service and
Caption: they stop the speech recognition service
Caption: or listening to incoming audio these
Caption: best to think about stop is that a lot
Caption: we've stopping it it also attempts to
Caption: return a result captured from the
Caption: microphone we're also going to need some
Caption: event endless most of them simply listen
Caption: there changes in recognition status so
Caption: the Tory I'm gonna focus on about result
Caption: and on speech end so you aren't result
Caption: who run or whatever a word or phrase has
Caption: been recognized and this basically
Caption: happens every single time
Caption: is the use off speak a word or several
Caption: ways in quick succession on a speech
Caption: edit what this does is just running
Caption: where the services stop being detected
Caption: it's kind of like if you pause for any
Caption: length of time that's where this is
Caption: going to fire now last thing this is
Caption: going to be the most complicated thing
Caption: I'm going to explain to you all day so
Caption: that this is going to set the scene for
Caption: how fun the rest is going to be the
Caption: speech recognition API is a little bit
Caption: complicated in that it can return
Caption: multiple results and multiple options of
Caption: those results so what happens is we can
Caption: get the result list the speech
Caption: recognition result this project and that
Caption: has the speech recognition result object
Caption: and that has the speech recognition
Caption: results alternatives which is a little
Caption: bit confusing but as I say because the
Caption: speech recognition API rhetorical
Caption: results it kind of needs a few ways in
Caption: which you can access these for the
Caption: purposes of today we're just going to
Caption: get one result and we're going to focus
Caption: on this feature increasing prism speech
Caption: recognition alternative object which is
Caption: where the transcript for the text that
Caption: it thought I heard from the microphone
Caption: place sorry in our court it's going to
Caption: look like this we have our list object
Caption: we get the best result the first result
Caption: and the transcript and we can throw that
Caption: all together into a function the only
Caption: extra thing I'm doing here aside from
Caption: using what I've already shown you is
Caption: looking for a div on the page actually
Caption: melody of a paragraph but that's more
Caption: semantically correct and then I am
Caption: updating the content on results to cause
Caption: the result of my speech recognition
Caption: object to keep today that's it and
Caption: that's how my making that example all
Caption: this code is all you need to do that so
Caption: you can see that it's really simple to
Caption: get started with using speech
Caption: recognition API but if you want it you
Caption: don't have to just print text out on
Caption: screen you can you know do something a
Caption: bit more fun like like this this is my
Caption: Michael Frank I love dogs my dog sign is
Caption: jelly this is my notes alter-ego Mel boy
Caption: who's a good boy
Caption: these are good boy so all I'm doing new
Caption: with this is detecting for a specific
Caption: phrase and when that phrase is detected
Caption: by the speech recognition API I'm
Caption: changing subjects on the page in my SVG
Caption: and also automating the tagging ievel so
Caption: it does play the ball and it's a way
Caption: so there's like a bunch of things that
Caption: you can do with this you don't have to
Caption: just think about it in terms of printing
Caption: text out of the screen what I think is
Caption: really interesting about it is that it's
Caption: going to allow us to create more
Caption: interactive and more
Caption: experiences if you think about the fact
Caption: that not everyone is going to use our
Caption: computers that our website - using a
Caption: keyboard and a mouse sometimes people
Caption: are using other kinds of inputs and we
Caption: can provide that with different aspects
Caption: of our websites I had a conversation
Caption: with someone at my work about using
Caption: speech recognition to allow people to
Caption: search the page maybe you want them to
Caption: be on a stop and stop video or navigate
Caption: between your page with speech
Caption: recognition there are a lot of
Caption: opportunities there so the next thing
Caption: that I wanted to talk about was device
Caption: orientation so point about web enabled
Caption: devices have something like a gyroscope
Caption: or an accelerometer and that can
Caption: determine the device's orientation and
Caption: return some information on that it's
Caption: commonly seen in things like mobile
Caption: devices to automatically rotate your
Caption: screen to the right way up I really
Caption: think that so I turn it off
Caption: but that's the way we see it a lot of
Caption: the time and it's just going to allow us
Caption: to access that information about the
Caption: device in order to use that black speech
Caption: recognition we need a couple of things
Caption: the first if the device orientation
Caption: event and this provides the information
Caption: on the physical orientation of the
Caption: device that we're using and from that we
Caption: can then access and view properties
Caption: specifically there are three called
Caption: alpha gamma and beta and they return
Caption: different number values depending on the
Caption: device orientation so the first one is
Caption: the Alpha property and this is basically
Caption: the direction that the device is facing
Caption: so if you think about it it's kind of
Caption: like turning it around in a circle much
Caption: like a compass it has a range from 0 to
Caption: 360 the second one is the beta of
Caption: company and this represents tooting the
Caption: whole lives are influenced and backwards
Caption: and that has a range of minus 180 280
Caption: and then the last one is the gamma
Caption: property and this is represented by
Caption: tucking the phone at left all right
Caption: and it's arranged minus 90 to 90 so in
Caption: order to use it the first thing we have
Caption: to do is check that we have access to
Caption: this information so we can just see if
Caption: it exists in the window if it does we
Caption: can add an event listener of device
Caption: orientation and then we can pass the
Caption: function in this is an example of one
Caption: super simple all I'm doing is getting
Caption: the government property if it's minus 50
Caption: I'm going to do something and this code
Caption: is specifically how I make this demo as
Caption: you can see my phone is cracked
Caption: probably from playing the device
Caption: orientation and don't pay attention not
Caption: really I drop my phone all the time all
Caption: I'm doing here is as firing the tools
Caption: and reaches a negative 50 gamma value
Caption: I'm just updating the CSS of my text and
Caption: going over to the side of the screen
Caption: this is also American fun so it also
Caption: tilts based on the camera orientation
Caption: but there's a lot of the simple kind of
Caption: interactive things that you can do with
Caption: that another example which is texted
Caption: back based because you don't know I like
Caption: to make a lot of text effects this
Caption: example is one that I use a lot it might
Caption: take the VEX presentation on its coldest
Caption: pathetical out I use it to demo a simple
Caption: text effects what I'm doing here is
Caption: using the orientation of the phone to
Caption: move the position of the background
Caption: gradient so that gives shifts along the
Caption: text this all I'm doing is using that
Caption: point that I showed you before but try
Caption: seeing the value of the gamma property
Caption: through to the gradient percentage you
Caption: can also do something like this I took
Caption: this SVG off I start breaking up into
Caption: parts and move the water and moon at
Caption: different instances
Caption: unfortunately I can't show you that life
Caption: because you would be upset what I think
Caption: is really interesting about device
Caption: orientation is we see the one in pink
Caption: line augmented reality even games
Caption: and these days will search through some
Caption: UI effects more commonly parallax
Caption: effects but for me what I think is
Caption: really exciting about it is it allows us
Caption: to create more interactive experience
Caption: that shaped by the music right now a lot
Caption: of our interactions are predetermined
Caption: you might click some letter but that's
Caption: going to happen exactly the same way for
Caption: every single person that uses leather or
Caption: our website device orientation that the
Caption: speech recognition API keeps uses the
Caption: opportunity to change that experience
Caption: and to create something that's specific
Caption: just to them it gives them more control
Caption: over the experience that they have it if
Caption: you're doing branding sites or other
Caption: training sites who you want them to age
Caption: easy to have a different experience
Caption: these are the kinds of things are like
Caption: to do that if you an artist or a
Caption: designer and you want to express
Caption: yourself differently to every single
Caption: person that comes to your site you can
Caption: do that for these kinds of events and
Caption: that brings me to the last one which is
Caption: my favorite I like to experiment with
Caption: the five senses a lot because I think
Caption: that the works interesting and very
Caption: versatile of the senses on the web
Caption: basically the ambient light sensor is a
Caption: quarter detective that's used to sense
Caption: the amount of ambient light that's in
Caption: the room it's pretty much found in
Caption: everyone otherwise
Caption: laptops happen
Caption: as a TVs as well you might see it
Caption: commonly it's used to do something super
Caption: practical which is to give your screen
Caption: is Lorelei environments to take the
Caption: string of your eyes TVs also use it for
Caption: similar reasons so that you can get see
Caption: black of blacks and that kind of stuff
Caption: so much like the other examples that
Caption: I've shown you we needed a couple of
Caption: things and we don't need a lot to use
Caption: the ambient light sensor first we need
Caption: the to granitic instance of the enemy of
Caption: the light sense up and what that's going
Caption: to do is give us access to all of the
Caption: information about the light in the room
Caption: we're going to need a couple of that
Caption: handless specifically we need them on
Caption: reading this isn't actually part of the
Caption: ambient light sensor api there is a
Caption: generic sense of api expect that a lot
Caption: of the sensors that you can use on the
Caption: web use on bringing is part of that and
Caption: all it does is coal whatever a reading
Caption: is taken the reading frequency for the
Caption: any light sensor is determined by you
Caption: you can possible to a property to that
Caption: senses constructor and that will tell
Caption: you how many radians per second to take
Caption: so the purposes of today we just take
Caption: all the information it wants to give us
Caption: the last thing we need is to return the
Caption: current light level of the room the only
Caption: thing we need for that is the
Caption: illuminance property and this returns a
Caption: Lux value which is just a number value
Caption: representing life but we really need to
Caption: work
Caption: two months because you figure it out
Caption: based on how bright it is or how dark it
Caption: is this is on the quarry that we need
Caption: you on it to do something with the
Caption: ambient light sensor attention that we
Caption: have access to any livestock waves I
Caption: create a new instance I'm looking for a
Caption: rating and then if it's less than 20 I'm
Caption: going to make the background black the
Caption: toilet 20 I'm going to make the employee
Caption: that's what we really need to do so it's
Caption: pretty dark in here
Caption: so let me show you an example that I
Caption: have made to this is my baby
Caption: let's see if it works with my bath and
Caption: torch it's what the lighting appears to
Caption: be weird so I might need to use my
Caption: favorite okay
Caption: so depending on how bright it is in the
Caption: room we depend up on with what you see I
Caption: really love that I got to use my diamond
Caption: so you can do all sorts of things with
Caption: these fries again like I was saying
Caption: before I've also got this one for those
Caption: Victorian home I like to make an
Caption: experiment with very good clumps and
Caption: this is a very fun this was the first
Caption: demo way that I ever made with an
Caption: ambient light sensor and what it does is
Caption: depending on how bright it is my trusty
Caption: Batman will depend on the
Caption: wait on the phone this is a coupon is
Caption: called tiny I like it because it really
Caption: demonstrates like super brightness but
Caption: what is really cool about this to me is
Caption: that with variable buns because you can
Caption: control the access and the style of the
Caption: fonts depending on various types of
Caption: people it's whether it's Herman CSS or
Caption: JavaScript if the room is really dot
Caption: that the user is in much like they
Caption: demonstrate you might want to increase
Caption: the weight from your front to make it
Caption: easier than them to read in the instance
Caption: all of my Sun and Moon if you are going
Caption: to experience when you're writing a
Caption: story or but let's put imagine for a
Caption: second you are writing a story about a
Caption: class and you're walking through the
Caption: forest and it's in the middle of the day
Caption: so it's really stupid nice but then they
Caption: come back and look at it at nighttime
Caption: and I tell spooky in this ass and it's
Caption: really dumb and it's scary
Caption: you can do this I mean you're uses
Caption: different experiences depending on the
Caption: situation that they're in and I think
Caption: that is the coolest thing because it's
Caption: on the market the web is like a level
Caption: above pre-money interactivity but this
Caption: kind of stuff lets us take it to a whole
Caption: new place keeping up with oh sorry to
Caption:  out what I wanted to say you start
Caption: being limited by what we can already do
Caption: on the web the web is a really really
Caption: young place and there's still so much
Caption: for us to create and what I hate seeing
Caption: is people going oh no ones that have
Caption: done that too it can't be done that's
Caption: not true
Caption: senses and API these are the opportunity
Caption: for us to create something new and
Caption: exciting that nobody has ever seen
Caption: before and everyone in this room is
Caption: capable of doing that you don't need a
Caption: lot of coin to get this going and you
Caption: don't need a lot of experience being in
Caption: developer in order to do that to be
Caption: honest I think most of it is just
Caption: creativity so there are a couple of
Caption: examples I wanted to finish up on they
Caption: combine these api's this uses the
Caption: ambient light sensor so if it's bright
Caption: in the group it will show a spotlight on
Caption: the text I think he know might've just
Caption: crashed there we go
Caption: there we go
Caption: so it is doc and I'm sorry if it's
Caption: bright enough you get the spotlight and
Caption: you'll get to read the secret message
Caption: that said but you have to use the black
Caption: screen taken in order to agree not so a
Caption: basis being getting rid of a black and
Caption: it disappears so that's kind of sonic
Caption: like puzzle games and it requires both
Caption: inputs in order for you to play the top
Caption: so another one that I made if you might
Caption: see on Twitter this is I just wanted to
Caption: show you what that I already taken to
Caption: apply so you can do this you will fire
Caption: around but I wanted to show you it for
Caption: real so that you believed me when I said
Caption: it because I can show you the
Caption: orientation on my laptop
Caption: it doesn't come a gyroscope but I can't
Caption: show you the beam so you turn the light
Caption: on
Caption: yeah I bet you know what's coming so let
Caption: me just get into position here click
Caption: commence abduction
Caption: [Music]
Caption: if the beam is on if it's or even the
Caption: cat and you said the words commence a
Caption: dozen if that fails that you cannot
Caption: adult the little kitty cat
Caption: sorry kind of think about what you can
Caption: do you think about the funny experiences
Caption: that you can see these I think in that
Caption: way that you can use this to create
Caption: these fun experiences for users thanks
Caption: very much
Caption: [Applause]